[Music]
[Applause]
Mike Tirico on the call with Chris
Collinsworth last night next Sunday
it'll be a battle of two of the best in
the NFC the Cowboys and the 49ers kick
off at 8 20 Eastern on NBC and peacock
and Mike Tarico kind enough to join us
Mike thanks for joining us take us into
the production meeting of what to expect
everything that's discussed leading into
that game including Taylor Swift
hi DP uh yeah we started talking gosh I
guess I guess really a week ago today of
you know does Taylor show up in New York
and if so how do you strike the balance
and then I think it was Dan either late
Monday or Tuesday with the ratings from
the Chiefs Bears blowout came out and
you saw that the viewership with the age
group that would be the swifties women
18 to 49. it was still higher than
normal
and the game was terrible so you thought
there might be a factor as the week went
on the NFL bought in and all that stuff
so you had an idea that you'd have a
different audience my Approach and our
producer Rob Highland we talked about
this a lot during the week we kind of
landed landed the plane here we've got
an average of about 20 million viewers
every week you got to be loyal to those
viewers but just welcome in the people
who might be watching might be sampling
the game and just try to find a balance
are there too many Taylor Swift shots or
they're not enough you could debate that
all week depending on which side of the
aisle you're on so we just try to strike
a balance not let it take away from the
game and thankfully we ended up having a
pretty good game anything that comes
close to that the surrealness of it
you mean the Taylor Factor
no I mean there's celebrities there
Rogers is back in the building uh I mean
this is a different game that you're
calling I don't know if you've had
anything that was similar
no no because you could truly make the
argument and this is no disrespect to
the reigning MVP of the league who is
the face of the league I think right now
in Patrick Mahomes I mean you can't go a
quarter watching the NFL without seeing
Mahomes Hawking something right and
selling something on a commercial but
the two people of the most Intrigue and
interest in the stadium were sitting in
Suites in Aaron Rodgers and Taylor Swift
so that that was a little different
we've done games where presidents or
celebrities or big stars of other sports
are sitting there but I think that the
phenomenon that we saw this summer with
Taylor Swift combined with the phenomena
we saw this summer with Aaron Rodgers
coming to the Jets but those two are an
intersection that I've never been around
for a game not not at all so it kind of
made for a cool night
we're one month into the season if you
were going to declare something
what would you declare
a team a player yeah I thought the AFC
was so much better than it has been and
maybe it'll kind of play itself out the
next couple of months and I'll I'll go
to this headline Dan I think the Jets
are okay
even though they're one in three so if I
if I tell you that you're gonna play
Kansas City and buffalo and Dallas and
you're going to end up in those three
games going one and two that's okay
because those are the best those were in
The Velvet Rope inside the Velvet Rope
those are VIP team I think in the NFL I
think most people would agree the
Patriots loss is going to be a bad one
for them but you all have a bad loss or
two as the year goes on unless the
margin for error with the Jets is gone
but I think the AFC we thought would
have more really good teams it's not
there right now two of the AFC East
right the AFC North everybody's beat up
Baltimore looks a notch above everybody
Cleveland's struggling with the offense
picket injury in Pittsburgh and
obviously borrowing Cincinnati FC South
Houston's been a big surprise for I
think all of us nobody's been Dynamic
and dynamite there and Out West the
Chargers look a little bit better the
Chiefs have been good the other two
teams not so much so I think there's
going to be an opportunity for a nine
and eight or an eight and nine to get it
in out of the AFC
did you get a chance to talk to Zach
Wilson uh prior to the game you guys sit
down with him in a production meeting
we did we we sat with him for 15 20
minutes for sure and what what strikes
you what uh jumps out at you
fine in the game so I'm glad I'm on so I
can get it in now
got a little bit of a tabloid Teflon on
him now I think he got beat up by the
back pages and the New York Press so
much for you know getting benched a
couple of times you're the Savior the
franchise guy year one okay it's a
rookie year two it's really tough you
get hurt in the first quarter of the
preseason you get bench you get all the
stories of what's his personal life and
all this other stuff and he went through
all of that he came through the other
side and this year he actually was
enjoying the process of being with Aaron
Rodgers and learning how to be a backup
quarterback learning this new system I
mean he was given a guy who's got you
know all those skins on the wall to
learn from and he was just soaking up
all of it I don't think he expected to
get thrown in so now that he does he's
seen that he's taken the Heat and
survived it so I think he actually has a
much fresher approach to it and I
thought he played really well last night
Chris Collinsworth who's all over it
from that second drive because the
second quarter on that might have been
the best night that Zach has had he's
had a good game he had a really good
game I think he's going to be all right
I think they're going to be all right I
do and he chant did you talk to Aaron
Rodgers
I did I did I actually went down to the
field before the game as we usually do
and Aaron was just sitting on the bench
uh it was really before a lot of folks
got on the field and we spoke for about
15 minutes I found him to be you know
one he said he was just gutted it just
broke him
um when he got hurt he just couldn't
believe it but he is he has been diving
in Full full steam to his rehab uh as
aggressive as possible he's great
because he loves his chip on his
shoulder and I started talking about
next year and he's like hey you never
know you know he's trying to he's trying
to Edge back to this year and then even
he alluded to well why is saying just
one year right I'm gonna come back just
for one y'all coming back
um so he's got a great positive energy
about him and Dan I think this person
is going to help the cats going forward
one for Zach Wilson two for the entirety
of the office
guys the bestie slime
uh I think we got a bad connection there
Mike uh safe safe travels home and uh I
know you got 49ers and Cowboys and we
appreciate you joining us